amidst those freezing temperatures and
blackouts world leaders and
international organizations have met in
Paris today pledging over 850 million
pounds in Urgent winter aid for Ukraine
we're joining me now to discuss the
sheer scale of the challenge ahead
defense and security analyst Professor
Michael Clarke Michael just give us a
bit more information about what's being
discussed today in Paris yes a quite a
big meeting it's a donors conference
um it began by President macron saying
that the Russians are committing war
crimes in targeting civilian facilities
and of course analysts like me have been
saying that for a while but when a key
leader says it out out loud like that
that's quite important it's a war crime
it's targeting the civilian
infrastructure
um they're talking about donors uh there
were not just uh States involved 40 odd
States but about 20 International
organizations very important and also
about 500 companies the sort of
companies that will need to get involved
in any reconstruction for the uh for the
country but of course the relentless
bombing just goes on even though the
student conference is meeting under the
the shadow of this bombing and this is a
NASA photograph of um light in the in
the uh during the during the night this
is the light you can see in Europe and
there is Ukraine
um almost completely blacked out there's
one there's only one other place in the
world where you'd see that and that's
North Korea which is always completely
black out in Asia but that sort of gives
you a sense of just how
total this this war on Ukraine's
infrastructure has really become yeah
it's incredible Ukraine needs so much in
terms of weapons to continue fighting
the war but money to help its people and
to rebuild when it can and to repair
constantly as people try to live in the
country we talk about 850 million pounds
being pledged today but various pledges
have been made by various different
groups of countries various individual
countries where are we at in terms of
Aid yeah I mean this is the the sort of
Aid that has been pledged so far so it's
about 110 billion quite a lot of money
most of it you'll see is financial which
the ukrainians have to have just to keep
going five to nine billion every month
just to keep functioning and their
military aid which has been delivered
far less inhumanitarian Aid and the
ukrainians are complaining not
surprisingly that this is pledged but it
hasn't all been delivered and that's
always the problem that you know pledges
pledging is easy delivering is a bit
more complicated and the Western allies
really need to get on with delivering
because Ukraine's Got to get through the
winter yeah 110 billion a lot but that
kind of scale is it enough how much more
is needed well there's some interesting
historical comparisons everyone talks
about the uh the Marshall Plan after the
second World War I mean if you take
Ukrainian Aid now the pledge day is 111
billion the Marshall Plan in in
present-day prices would be about 134
billion at the time it was about 13
billion dollars so it's about 10 times
that amount now and that was what the
Marshall Plan did what the Ukraine
reconstruction is probably in the order
of 600 billion
um the international monetary fund and
the World Bank said in July they thought
it was about 350 billion then in
December they said they thought it had
probably now gone up to five or six
hundred billion so that's where we are
with it now an immense amount still to
do incredible uh Michael thank you
Professor Michael Clark there with
analysis of what's happening with regard
to Ukraine today